nous sommes en direct avec umaru qu al
agha spécialiste des relations
internationales
monsieur koala gars bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france depuis
le burkina faso vous trouvait justement
à ouagadougou dans les bureaux de vote
sont ouverts quelle est la situation sur
place
bonjour à ouagadougou on va dire que
c'est un jour de scrutin et comme prévu
les unes a fait tout le dispositif
électoral est de type étreinte
les électeurs ont commencé à exprimer
les ouvrages et donc pour le moment à
ouagadougou où les informations que nous
avons le monde tout se passe assez bien
pour un scrutin qui se déroule sous
tension des tensions politiques
également sur le terrain on sait qu'il
n'ya pas il est lu pas mal d'attaquants
jihadistes
l'opposition elle craint avant même
voilà l'annoncé des résultats des
fraudes elles ne veulent pas évidemment
que le président sortant accédants un
nouveau mandat est ce qu'ils ont des
preuves justement d'irrégularités bah
écoutez vous savez l approche des
échéances comme celle ci c'est de bonne
guerre que dans chacun en plus à la
limite avoir un certain nombre
d'opinions qui peuvent diverger
l'opposition effectivement envie de
venir aussi est de conquérir le pouvoir
et donc en estimant que aujourd'hui le
candidat sortant a l'avantagé d'avoir
beaucoup plus de ressources est beaucoup
plus de mobilisation va des gens dans
une certaine mesure c'est de prévenir
donc tout ceci pour déjà crié j'allais
dire
il s'éteint dynamique pour éviter que
les uns et les autres à nice et mais je
pense que amp les deux opinions
il y à des observateurs internationaux
qui sont là il y a
beaucoup de trains internationaux y
compris notre statut qui a mobilisé pour
être si les lieux cela développe normes
a contribué à diminuer cette méfiance
entre les deux corées mais je pense que
c'est de bonne guerre comme dans toute
élection
alors on l'a dit depuis le départ de
blaise compaore le pouvoir n'arrive pas
à endiguer une certaine violence et où
se mêlent djihadisme et tensions
communautaires
quel est le candidat qui pourrait amener
le plus
voilà la paix dans le pays bas à cette
question j'allais dire que tous les
prétendants légitimement peut selon les
offres politiques selon les projets
programmes des candidats ont tous envie
mais évidemment quand vous regardez la
liste je sais qu'il ya au moins je veux
dire du candidat sortant on a quand même
deux ou trois candidats qui peuvent
aussi voir beaucoup plus les lois ne
soient que le soutien je pense notamment
au cdb je pense
voilà l'ancien régime qui après jeudi
les événements de 2014 a envie de
prendre une certaine revanche elle est
revenue au pouvoir ils ont du monde ils
ont des ressources
ils ont un potentiel en dehors du cdp on
n'a jamais de l'upc de zéphirin diabré
qui aujourd'hui en dépit de quelques
défections au sein deux sons sont 1000
deux de son parti il a quand même aussi
un réel potentiel il a un bon maillage
du territoire en terme de mobilisation
camelots et le militant et puis vous
avez aussi même s'il n'est pas sur le
terrain
l'ancien président de la transition par
isaac sida qui a quand même aussi un
certain nombre de personnes qui croient
lui qui mobilise et puis vous avez
jamais dit ou tellement en dernière
position dans une moindre mesure
l'ancien président de la commission de
la cedeao ch pas de désir est cadré tout
ceci
ces candidats ont un potentiel mais avec
légèrement c'est un avantage pour le
candidat sortant parce que quand tu as
fait sega bon il ya quand même un léger
avantage mais je pense que c'est une
copie sans compétition qui est très très
très ouverte et on attend de regarder ce
que cela va donner
on verra si les mobilisations des uns et
les autres à porter fruits de mer ou
après demain
voilà une élection assez ouverte mais
est-ce que selon vous l'insécurité
justement qui est lié au djihadisme peut
freiner les électeurs à se rendre aux
urnes notamment dans certaines régions
est ce qu'on s'attend à beaucoup de
monde aujourd'hui
je crois que la commission nationale
indépendante a communiqué aux régates de
l'évaluation sécuritaire a d'office
exclus un certain nombre de régions à
paris deux régions deux municipalités
je crois 15 municipalités pour des
raisons évidentes de sécurité ou pas de
maîtrise contrôle de la situation mais
en dehors de ça je crois qu'il ya eu un
travail qui a été fait le climat il
était plus ou moins serein en dehors de
jeudi matin qu'il y a eu à deux semaines
qui a créé une certaine psychose
il ya une commission ceux qui luttaient
qui est mise en place est dans le
président de la ceni d'ailleurs le
président et qui à l'ensemble de tous
les composantes pour cette élection on à
l'armée habituellement n'avait pas la
même et c'est seulement au regard de ce
défi sécurité toutes les forces de
défense et de sécurité sont mobilisés
il ya un certain nombre de dispositifs
on nous a rassurés qui va permettre non
seulement de dissuader mais au peuple un
peu plus loin même un peu plus robuste
il y à des unités qui sont prêts pts par
les régions où il ya beaucoup plus de
difficultés à intervenir au cas où il y
avait ça allait dire des vérités ou de
tentatives de déstabilisation
donc il n'y a jamais de risque zéro dans
une question sécurité mais également et
quand on regarde comme nous en tant
qu'espèce de la question c'est qui était
quand on a régalé quelques éléments on
peut sans être ou verser dans un
optimisme béat à filmer que
cette question sécuritaire a été prise
en compte et que la capacité de nuisance
des fausses j'allais dire ennemis plus
en compte et que normalement quand vous
regardez depuis ce matin on a un
dispositif qui est assez dissuasif
je pense que c'est une donne qui a été
prise en compte et on devrait pouvoir
avoir des élections dans un climat plus
ou moins stabilisé et apaisée merci
beaucoup
oumarou koala gars d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste des relations
internationales et vous étiez en direct
de ouagadougou